bonsoir les selles qu'heroes merci
d'être avec nous des résultats donc
ultra serré actuellement on imagine
qu'il ya beaucoup de tension à ce que
vous avez eu des nouvelles du perron
comment les choses se trament alors oui
en effet les résultats sont extrêmement
serrés autour de 50% de deux millions de
bulletins exprimés pour pedro castillo
et 49 pour keiko fujimori à peu près on
est à 90 % des suffrages des bulletins
scruter et l'ambiance est extrêmement il
ya une forte tension on en attend les
parisiens attendent en fait depuis 2018
qui lie à un président élu et
démocratiquement élu puisque on est en
fait en vacance de pouvoir depuis 7,7
cette année la fin de 2018 où le
président pedro pablo kuczynscki a dû
démissionner donc depuis on est dans une
sorte boucle
certaines stade instabilité politique et
les péruviens ou plus était vraiment
très sont déplacés aux urnes vote est
obligatoire pour les péruviens à l'épée
reviennent donc là vraiment c'est
l'aspect tactile on attend les résultats
mais on est prêt de la fin du
dépouillement des scrutins est en effet
comme vous l'avez dit dans votre sujet
les votes exprimés dans les régions
surtout les régions les plus pauvres les
régions des andes et de l'amazone y ont
fortement compté dans le vote favorable
à pedro castillo qui explique justement
que c'est rural et temps pesé en faveur
de la gauche radicale qu'elle que fuji
mounir représente à la fois le le
les partis traditionnels puisque le
sujet maurice mme est un mouvement
politique qui a été fondé par son père
alberto fujimori en 1990 et depuis le
pérou et marquer enfin pas depuis mais
en tout cas ça s'est accentué durant ce
gouvernement par la corruption qui est
vraiment structurel de toute la sphère
politique français paix revienne pardon
que ce soit au niveau de l'exécutif
légistatives voir le judiciaire et donc
ça ce sont des votes plutôt urbain alors
que pedro castillo qui est un professeur
des écoles à professeurs des écoles
d'une région andine
il est syndicaliste il représente plutôt
l'alternative populaire rurale et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est qui est vraiment
ce sont ces régions qui ont été plus
sensibles à ce discours est un discours
qui revendique justement l'inclusion de
ces zones qui ont été oubliés qui sont
marginalisés d'une certaine manière de
lait d'un point de vue économique et
social par exemple on l'a vu durant la
pandémie peu d'hôpitaux pratiquement pas
de médecins qui sont concentrés dans les
villes et en particulier à l'imam c7
c'est ce père ou là qui s'est mobilisé
pour justement demander la fin de la
corruption
et il ya un investissement de l'état
beaucoup plus importante pour ces
régions alors deux candidats on le
rappelle diamétralement opposées la
droite populiste d'un côté la gauche
radicale de l'autre quelle que soit
l'issue de cette élection est ce qu'on
ne risque pas d'avoir un pays encore peu
fracture est divisée oui enfin ça c'est
un fait le pérou est un pays qui est
polarisée on voit bien dans concept dans
ces élections
il est polarisée il sera très difficile
pour la personne qui occupera
qui sera président ou présidente de
gouverner puisque que ce soit au niveau
de l'expression des bulletins et des
votes du péruvien et paix revienne mais
aussi au parlement au congrès en le
gouvernement n'aura pas une majorité
donc il n'aura pas même pas cette lune
de miel qui existent en général durant
un an pour pour la nouvelle présidence
là il faudra vraiment composé faire des
alliances politiques donc ce ne sera pas
du tout facile c'est vraiment pas un
cadeau pour la personne qui arrivera au
pouvoir le 28 juillet puisque c'est le
26 juillet le jour de l'investiture au
pérou et donc il faudra vraiment faire
organiser un gouvernement qui qui combat
qui agissent très rapidement plus
particulièrement je pense pour ces
millions de personnes qui sont dans la
pauvreté le perron compte quand même une
trame durant cette année de pandémie eh
bien on a vu le nombre de pauvres
travaux augmenté on est à trois millions
de personnes sur un pays qui compte 30
millions donc vous voyez c'est quand
même extrêmement important le pays plus
touchés des l'amérique latine par le col
et 19 vraiment on a tout un chantier
social important a pour la nouvelle
présidence qui arrivera donc en juillet
mature et enfin en tout cas à rajouter
des tensions et des crispations le clan
de keiko fujimori crie à la fraude
depuis que son adversaire donc on en
parlait de la gauche est passé devant
elle a dénoncé des irrégularités et une
volonté de saboter la volonté du peuple
les officiels indiquent n'avoir relevé
aucun incident majeur
on imagine que c'est quand même le
poison qui est distillée
même si on sait pas qui croire dans
cette affaire oui bon ça je pense que
c'est ce sont des méthodes un
politicienne qui sont résidents de déjà
vu et connu il faut savoir que quelqu'un
fût immolé quand même content avec toute
la l'appui des médias
il ya c'était un parti le fujimorisme
comme je vous le disais existe depuis
décennies des décennies
il ya eu toute la bourgeoisie péruvienne
les les classes supérieures dont
péruvienne qui sont qui ont qu'il rompt
lui ont donné leur appui
donc vraiment elle compte avec beaucoup
de moyens donc là c'est une façon de
peser un peu de mettre un peu la
pression sur certains enfin de
l'organisation qui est dépouille de
dépouillement là on paie qui dépouillent
les bêtas au pérou et pour mesure
deuxième dans cette stratégie je dirais
plutôt politicienne parce qu'au début
lorsque les noter qu il était favorable
on parlait pas du tout de fraude
au contraire où on respectait le travail
de 7,2 et organismes c'est cette
institution je pense que là c'est parce
que les fujimoristes on sentent le vent
tourner et là la différence je pense que
ça sera pas ne sera pas possible de
rattraper au mont reste qu'en huit sur
dix victoires prend très probable de
l'europe et de location
merci beaucoup au lycée la pierre aux
spécialistes du perron professeur des
universités en études latino américaines
à l'université cergy paris